que peut-on faire que peut-on encore
faire la france n'a pas été très active
dans ce conflit
l'europe non plus comme le déplorait
sylvain tesson c'était sur france inter
il ya trois jours
ce qui est absolument assourdissant
silence qui a régné de la part de
l'europe qui n'a même pas daigné
considéré qu'il y avait eu des
manquements profond aux droits de
l'homme et aux conventions d'aidé
conflit le président macron a tout de
même réagi en pointant le fait que
c'était une agression azéri et turcs
l'exécutif français a également signalé
qu'il y avait eu l'emploi de mercenaires
djihadistes keaven qui avait été
transfusé des francs du kurdistan syrien
et qui avait été dépêché par
l'intermédiaire de la turquie d'erdogan
artisous constant les armes s
il y a eu cette intervention donc du
président macro mais du côté de la
diplomatie française c'était prudence
prudence
écoutez cette intervention du ministre
les affaires étrangères jean yves le
drian
c'était au sénat trois jours après le
cessez le feu
il importe que ce cessez-le-feu soit
respectée cette guerre a été meurtrière
cette guerre a été une très grande
brutalité
elle a été dramatique les combats
maintenant cesser il faut qu'il soit
respecté totalement de toutes les
parties il faut que s'ouvre maintenant
les discussions sur la base du
cessez-le-feu pour en conclure les
différents paramètres et pour faire en
sorte qu'un vrai règlement du conflit
dans le haut-karabakh puisse se tenir
sur le long
jean christophe buisson ça rappelle la
phrase d'un autre ministre des affaires
étrangères qui était socialiste aussi
c'était au siècle dernier
c'était après une intervention en europe
de l'est et des soviétiques et ce
ministre avait dit nous ne ferons rien
naturellement c'était claude cheysson
absolument ce sera la même chose cette
fois-ci vous croyez au haut karabakh la
france ne bougera pas d'abord la france
n'a pas bougé et c'est d'autant plus
surprenant que emmanuel macron
effectivement a eu des propos très très
engagé au début du conflit en désignant
effectivement l'agresseur en
l'occurrence l'azerbaïdjan et en
dénonçant le fait qu'il y avait des
djihadistes des mercenaires jihadiste
sur la foi d'informations partagées
d'ailleurs avec la russie d'informations
vérifiées qui laisse penser qu'il y
avait environ 3500 mercenaires
djihadistes venant d'idlib une région
qui est désormais contrôlée par la
turquie au nord de la syrie venus prêter
main forte à l'armée azerbaïdjanaise
elle même commandé en partie par des par
le haut commandement sur par des
généraux de sueur donc on voit bien que
c'était pas un conflit régional de cette
région qui a peu vraie grande comme la
gironde si vous voyez montagneuse certes
mais quand même pas papa très vaste
parce qu'un enjeu géopolitique et qui
est l'enjeu de la turquie en
l'occurrence quand macron a dit ça je
pense qu'il espérait qu'on condamnerait
fermement que l'europe le suivraient
dans cette condamnation et que le groupe
de minsk à laquelle appartient la france
les états unis et la russie
interviendrait que l'eau et ce dans le
cadre de laquelle se trouve le groupe de
minsk enverrait des vérificateurs on
verrait peut-être des tout de suite des
superviseurs de ce qui se passait il
s'est rien passé de tout ça pourquoi
parce que tout le monde
s'occuper des élections américaines à
commencer par les américains qui avaient
autre chose de plus important à gérer
que ce conflit même s'il était d'un
groupe de minsk était des élections en
pennsylvanie en géorgie où je ne sais où
tu ça plus la pandémie mondiale avec et
une indifférence coupable et je pense
qu'il est vraiment la friture entre
l'elysée et le quai d'orsay
parce que je pense que macron voulait
vraiment qu'on fasse quelque chose faire
quelque chose c'est ça peut être envoyés
de l'armement
vous allez me dire envoyer l'armement
mais on est neutres mais c'est ce qu'a
dit d'ailleurs jean yves le drian et
c'est la joie en venir mais à quel
moment on est neutres nous français qui
prétendent en faisant faire la guerre à
l'islamisme quand vous avez un pays qui
utilisent 3500 mercenaires djihadiste
islamiste pour faire la guerre un autre
pays
en l'occurrence chrétien mais la limite
ce n'est même pas le problème le
problème c'est que lorsqu'on combat
aujourd'hui au mali par exemple on
combat du côté du mali pourquoi parce
qu'on aide le mali à combattre les
islamistes sur le sur l'idée que
combattre les islamistes au mali c'est
nous protéger ses protégés le mali bien
surpasser nous protéger aussi et ce qui
marche au mali ça ne marche pas en
arménie avec pays avec lequel on a des
liens mais qui remonte au moyen âge avec
léon 5 de lusignan qui remonte au
génocide arménien de 1915 beaucoup
d'arméniens sont venus en france enfin
je vous connais c'est ça aussi bien que
moi donc il ya eu 7 7 7 friture sur la
ligne qui est d'autant plus déplorable
que là bas tous les gens nous disaient
ah si le figaro magazine vient ici c'est
que le gouvernement français va faire
quelque chose une conception de la
presse qu'il est un peu plus moi souffle
corps france mais en tout cas l'idée
était si l'afld que la presse française
vient même si on était un peu seul c'est
que le gouvernement français va nous
aider va intervenir et c'est ça qui m'a
qui m'a beaucoup frappé donc et est
maintenant alors ça c'était avant
maintenant qu'est ce qui peut se passer
déjà jean yves le drian a modelé un peu
son discours il laisse entendre que le
le le cessez le feu qui a abouti sur un
vague traité il va falloir en discuter
sérieusement parce que bon solo il
prévoit que toute la région aille à
l'azerbaïdjan sans conditions sans
protection du patrimoine religieux
culturel arménien il a peut-être compris
que cette région est peuplée à 90%
d'arméniens donc si on espère que les
arméniens s'appelle une épuration
ethnique même si ça s'est fait avec
moins de violence quand hugo slavik au
rwanda lui-même dit il faut il faut
qu'on discute des conditions il faut une
aide humanitaire
une aide humanitaire qui peut qui peut
être qui d'abord la priorité dans les
jours qui viennent avec ses dizaines de
milliers d'arméniens chasse et de
chasser de leurs
de leurs terres de leur habitation de
leur église donc je pense que désormais
la france
débarrassé de cette idée de guerre et
s'est décidée que si on intervient on ne
tient compte la turquie de fait est que
c'est le gros problème c'est comment se
fâcher avec erdogan qui non seulement
appartient à l'otan donc c'est un peu
compliqué mais ensuite à un robinet
comme vous le savez de migrants qui peut
ouvrir ou fermer à sa guise je pense que
c'est un petit peu ce qui a bloqué dans
l'idée que que la france intervienne pas
alors qu'encore une fois là bas
là-bas le pays est entouré d'ennemis
l'azerbaïdjan la turquie et de faux amis
la géorgie l'iran est un peu plus loin
la russie et dieu est très haut et la
france très loin comme disent les
polonais et en l'occurrence c'est ce qui
leur arrivait aussi aux arméniens
je vais vous donner la parole bien sûr
laurent joffrin mais je voudrais avant
tout faire un passage si vous le voulez
bien par les avis de nos amis
internautes ça se passe sur twitter ou
sur lefigaro.fr comme vous le souhaitez
le débat est très vif
nicole 06 nous dit une fois de plus on a
abandonné une terre chrétienne alors que
rome 37 91 soit scellé pseudo de nos
internautes considèrent que la france ne
doit aucunement s'engager c'est fini le
temps de l'impérialisme chardons bleus
semblent regretter l'absence de réaction
de jean-louis peut-être qu'on ne réagit
pas assez mais on est déjà au mali at-on
les moyens de s'engager dans un autre
conflit même si vous venez de l'indiquer
c'est pas forcément une intervention
militaire
archos qui de toute façon on ne peut pas
être sur tous les fronts
nous sommes la première armée d'europe
mais elle est limitée
et effectivement globalement nos
internautes en tout cas pour l'instant
à la question la france doit elle
s'engager davantage dans le conflit qui
touche le haut karabakh la réponse est
non à près de 60%
et vous laurent joffrin quelle est votre
réponse je pense que la france aurait pu
faire mieux oui alors il faut pas avoir
de d'illusions là-dessus on va pas
envoyer un corps expéditionnaire on
n'est plus au temps de la guerre de
crimée où j'étais évidemment mais on
aurait pu faire plus d'ailleurs et on
était impliqué depuis trop longtemps
dans ce conflit il ya pas seulement les
liens historiques avec les arméniens et
on a une communauté arménienne avec
laquelle la république a d'excellents
rapports depuis très longtemps et donc
c'est assez logique que l'on soit
solidaire même s'ils font parfois des
bêtises
mais on pouvait faire beaucoup mieux on
était dans le groupe de minsk on a
présidé le groupe de minsk on a cherché
à trouver un compromis dans cette
affaire qui étaient tranchées très
commencé mais il y avait un compromis
possible en consistant à consistant à
dire defacto on va reconnaître
l'indépendance pas forcément de la ford
relm et de la deûle enclave arménienne
qui est quand même peuplé d'arméniens
95% et en échange des arméniens vont
rendre ils ont conquis dans la dernière
guerre ils ont conquis des démarches eux
aussi pour eux pour se protéger des
districts où il ya qui sont peuplés
d'azéris l'azerbaïdjan début c'est à
nous il faut nous le rendre les
arméniens 10 vont bien moulant mais vous
reconnaissez notre le sanctuaire
arménien on aurait pu aller dans ce sens
là on voit d'ailleurs quand on revient
sur ces négociations là le le caractère
extrêmement nuisible de toute idéologie
nationaliste
parce que pourquoi ça a échoué c'est
parce que et les airs ils veulent
reprendre l'ancienne colonie qui était
le haut karabagh et les arméniens ne
veulent rien savoir sur les territoires
qu'ils avaient conquis sur les airs et
donc là où bien que l'extrême
nationalisme créer les conditions d'un
conflit extrêmement semblant d avant
d'être de nationalisme c'est quand même
rappelez vous que ces frontières là ont
été établis en 1921 par staline oui je
sais d'ailleurs qui la remet la
république d'artsakh des arméniens du
haut-karabakh demandé tout simplement
être rattachés à la république
soviétique d'arménie puisqu'il est
terminée assez staline qui a dit non non
on va vous mettre à l'intérieur de la
zone oblats ce qu on appelait ça à
l'intérieur république socialiste
soviétique d'azerbaïdjan alors que les
deux étaient dans l'urss à l'époque et
gambas et au début de l'urss également
les deux faisait partie du reste mais
staline
mélanger comme ça les populations vont
pas qui est trop d'homogénéité ethnique
et ce conflit-là n'a pas démarré
aujourd'hui n'a pas dès maintenant 93 il
démarre en 1988 avant la chute du mur de
berlin
lorsqu'il ya eu un million de personnes
dans les rues dans tout le haut karabakh
à demander son rattachement à l'arménie
et ensuite son indépendance pour pouvoir
se rattacher un jour on à l'arménie donc
s'il y avait une sorte de référendum
populaire
il y avait une logique à ce moment là
que les arbitres
du nom nous on veut pas or cette terre
les arméniens et des monastères qui date
d'une neuvième du 10ème siècle du 11e
siècle et même d'avant l'islam naissant
et 10 1% en arménien nokia sur c'est
aujourd'hui c'est repris par l' exagérer
une manière violente et on va et on va
déraciner une population qui fait 140
1959 le truc chez n'ont pas renoncé aux
6 et si on compare ça avec le kosovo
parce que c'est l'argument des azéri en
sur ce point de vue et c'est l'argument
de dire il faut pas qu'on intervient
parce que le droit international a donné
frontières mais ce qui s'est passé au
corps et moi y avait 90% d'albanais au
kosovo le morceau qui faisait partie de
la yougoslavie
ils ont demandé leur autonomie puis leur
indépendance et nous occidentaux
d'intervenir en leur faveur disant oui
vous avez le droit parce que les autres
vous massacrer on ne fait pas pour les
armer
exactement ces deux points il ya un
autre élément qui est un peu polémique
aussi mais c'est que en france il ya un
parti poutine aux ide consistant à dire
oui il faut parler avec poutine mais
c'est quand même d'une naïveté
incroyable cette histoire le poutine a
repris la politique traditionnelle de
sadeillan il faut créer autour de la
russie dans le cadre d'une démarche
un cordon est donc en ukraine on suscite
un conflit avec la minorité russophone
d'ukraine
on envoie des mercenaires on envoie des
troupes plus ou moins officieuse et ont
créé une espèce de gaz civile en ukraine
et ensuite on n'intervient pas il faut
mettre de l'ordre
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé
c'est pas les russes qui ont déclenché
le conflit mais ils ont laissé faire
maintenant ils ont ils ont leurs armes
etc et dans le sur le terrain mais pour
les arméniens wii ou que les russes
soient là malheureusement oui bien sûr
d'abord faut pas oublier que les russes
que c'est parce qu'ils sont chrétiens
comme pardon j'ai des questions basiques
mais non parce que c'est toujours parce
que leurs grandes engagé à ce que
l'arménie et restent fermées ni
arménienne sans le haut car ben reste
sous la direction d arméniens avalées
par un voisin
non mais n'oublions pas que d'abord il
ya une base militaire importante en
arménie république d'arménie à goumri au
nord ouest du pays qui est qui et là
effectivement et une pince russe base
russe base militaire russe qui est là et
qui effectivement poutine a dit tant que
la république d'arménie n'est pas touché
moi je m'en occupe pas parce qu'il
appartient au groupe de minsk encore une
fois et moi je respecte le droit
international on nous on est supposé
être naître le groupe 2000 dont je
regarde ça de loin comme un chat
regarder un petit peu les petites souris
et jouer avant de mettre sa grosse patte
mais il n'aimait pas le nouveau premier
ministre de l'arménie qui a dégagé du
pouvoir son prédécesseur corrompus qui
l'a même fait mettre en prison qui était
un grand ami et un oligarque proche de
poutine
donc depuis deux ans les relations sont
assez tendus entre l'arménie et la
russie mais le fait est que les
arméniens préfère de toute façon être
sous l'influencé voir l'occupation ou
quelque chose qui ressemble russe que
turque
les turcs c'est le génocide de 1915 les
azéris n'appelle pas les azéris l'appel
des tur pour eux c'est la même chose et
là où ils ont raison c'est que dans le
cercle proche dans l'accord qui a été
créé ce qu'on oublie un petit peu qu'ils
passent un gp à la cie un corridor qui
rejoint le marc rich evans qui est une
enclave azéri au sein de l'arménie avec
le haut karabagh azerbaïdjanaise qui
veut dire que désormais un espace turc
turcophones qui courent de l'istanbul
jusque là au round 6 chez les ouigours
aux-in yang sans discontinuité dans
cette histoire la turquie a gagné un
espace qui va de la mer noire à la mer
caspienne et c'est l arménie qui bloqué
au milieu et maintenant avec ce petit
corridor au sud qui coupe la frontière
entre l'arménie et l'iran et l'iran
était le premier partenaire commercial
de l'arménie donc en plus on étouffe
économiquement l'armée et c'est ça dont
la france doit discuter va discuter j'en
suis sûr parce que ce petit corridor
c'est c'est un cordon d'étranglement
économiques politiques géopolitiques
humanitaires de l'armée ni demain et
comme c'est aussi est à la fois
dramatique et assez complexe je me
permets de vous renvoyer à l'ensemble du
figaro magazine de ce week-end donc au
récit fait par sylvain tesson qui est
parti là-bas avec jean christophe
buisson et aussi pour comprendre ce
corridor à une carte assez complète que
nous avons réalisé
elle va demander un peu de travail pour
rendre ce sujet aussi compréhensible que
possible un autre point d'actualité
heureusement moins dramatique même s'il
va sans doute aussi susciter des
tensions
notre dame de paris vous vous souvenez
qu après l incendie il y a eu une
première polémique un premier débat pour
savoir s'il fallait reconstruire ou non
à l'identique la flèche de la cathédrale
finalement c'est la reconstruction à
l'identique qui l'a emporté et
maintenant voici que s'ouvre un autre
chantier celui de l'aménagement
intérieur de la cathédrale et
d'éventuels changements décoratifs
c'est un article de claire bommelaer
notre concert du figaro dans le journal
de ce matin qui suscite le débat puisque
l'archevêque de paris monseigneur aux
petits qui est qu'à la maîtrise de ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur de la
cathédrale voudrait proposer des
innovations alors la première d'entre
elle se serait de remplacer certains
vitraux qui n'ont pas été détruits par
l'incendié mais qui pourraient devenir
plus contemporain ces vitraux jusqu'à
présent était ce qu'on appelle des
grisailles alors pour ceux qui sont pas
les spécialistes de l'architecturé et de
la décoration des monuments religieux
gothique une grisaille ça ressemble à ça
ce sont donc des vitraux qui sont en
partie pain il date de viollet-le-duc
donc ils ne sont pas de l'origine de la
cathédrale mais ils ont été rajoutées au
19e siècle et puis il ya un autre projet
même si rien n'est décidé à ce stade qui
serait un réaménagement de du mobilier
liturgique peut-être en tout cas des
sièges delà de la cathédrale qui
pourraient devenir des bancs éclairé et
que la bôme l'art explique assez
drôlement que sur les dessins qu'elle a
vu ça ressemble un peu à un aéroport
voit un parking sur le principe
laurent joffrin est ce que vous vous
faites partie d'aider des gens qui
considèrent qu'il faut que ça évolue
tout le temps aux monuments historiques
ou bien que vous respectez ce qu'il
était je ne considère rien je constate
que les cathédrales
ont évolué au fil des siècles en
permanence si vous prenez la cathédrale
de strasbourg par exemple vous avez le
coeur et roman ensuite ses débuts du
goal du gothique et puis la façade donc
ouest la grande façade la plus
spectaculaire et datent de trois siècles
plus tard et les quatre toutes les
cathédrales de france pratiquement ont
fonctionné comme ça c'est comme elle
était construite sur plusieurs siècles
et comme on n'avait pas cette espèce de
religion c'est le cas de le dire de
l'origine on innovait en permanence le
gothique
il ya beaucoup de cathédrales gothiques
françaises qui ont été construites à la
place de l'ancienne cathédrale romane
qu'il fait très belle mais on détruisait
et on mettait en meute et une autre à la
place au même endroit et j'ai donc je
comprends mal ce débat yes a évolué tout
le temps et qu'on viollet-le-duc est
arrivé il a réinterprété les souvent les
quand il a fait reconstruire des choses
réinterpréter en disant je vais je vais
rentrer à dire l'esprit de l'époque mais
c'est pas du n'a pas copié ce qu'ils
avaient avant et par exemple ou la
flèche vous l'auriez re si vous avez été
président sera délicat après une
reconstruction à l'identique ou bien
vous auriez fait un truc plus moderne en
cristal ça dépend des projets
si le projet est beau et correspond bien
à l'esprit du lieu
pourquoi pas pourquoi ne pas innover ya
rien ne l'en empêche enfin notre pays
n'a pas de tradition la tradition des
cathédrales c'est la traduction de la
nouveauté c'est ça la vraie tradition ça
change tout le temps et derrière vous et
n'importe quelle était la cathédrale
vous avez des objets qui datent du 19e
du 16e mais il ya un
couche d'eau renaissance il ya une
couche de gothique flamboyant et puis un
bout de romans et énormément elles sont
faites de bric et de broc en fait elles
sont passées pas des objets qu'on
construit et pour ça qu'ils ont une âme
jean-christophe mais vous avez utilisé
un mot important c'est l'esprit
viollet-le-duc quand il fait ce qui te
fait il fait du néo gothique mais dans
le money gotti qui a gothic oui monsieur
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que des
bons et bien d'autres choses mais bon un
point lumineux je vois pas le rapport
avec un esprit vaguement catholiques
chrétiens religieux c'est ça mais ça
c'est les catholiques et ici c'est la
salle avec les noms mais vous avez
totalement raison et justement c'est le
deuxième point que je vais aborder le
problème c'est pas que vous vous
trouviez ça très bien le problème c'est
que l'église catholique elle-même
lancent ce genre d'initiatives notamment
à notre dame de paris ce qu'elle a
toujours fait mais pas pas n'importe où
c'est bien quand c'est quand le kazakh a
fait une tête de créer une église une
cathédrale à firminy où dans une ville
nouvelle moi ça me gêne pas qu'elle soit
en ciment qu'elle soit qu'elles soient
brut qu'elle corresponde à l'époque
parce que c'est une création
là on est en train de toucher à quelque
chose qui est une institution
d'abord c'est une institution c'est
tellement une situation que les
donateurs qui ont fait ce geste de
donner je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est une
fortune d'un milliard d'euros ils l'ont
fait avec l'idée qu'on restaure notre
nom de ce tarif là qu on la refait
autres ont fait ont l'art est
essentielle
ben non là en l'occurrence on cherche
des vitraux c'est bidon qui ont été
dégelés 3 rue pour aller changer les
rares des vitraux des cathédrales et
d'aujourd'hui ils sont souvent hélas
comme ils ont été ajoutées y compris des
modernes mais parce que ça a été détruit
par des guerres je vois quoi roux a
détruit six n'ont pas été détruits
justement ils ont été sauvés mais ça va
plus quand sa valeur sur l'église tony g
curieux les amateurs les congratuler de
calaisiens dont on parle si vous êtes
intéressé autre chose mais tout de suite
le mot de passe cissé préféré des
suisses en ligne je suis pas du tout
intégré je me réfère la chaire de vienne
qui est absolument pas religieux la
chambre ne vienne qui dit qu'on ne
touche pas des bâtiments si j'avais de
restaurer à l'identique de la dernière
fois donc heureux il ya même pas besoin
des restos ici puisque les vitraux
existe encore donc on les remet pro
finale parce que encore une fois c'est
notre dame
une autre dame de paris c'est pas une
cathédrale c'est pas strasbourg c'est
par un c'est pas nevers c'est notre dame
de paris
et si le monde entier s'est mobilisé
pour notre jeune paris c'est pas pour
mettre des déserts des javelles de
strasbourg est aussi important d box
d'aéropro non non non non je ne suis pas
d'accord vous qui décidez que celle là
est ce que mon avis je vais nôtre c'est
très dur elle sera vue subjectif la
objectivement c'est bien évidemment
puisque c'est un avis mais en
l'occurrence d'un de paris c'est au
dessus de tout le reste donc on touche
pas notre dame de paris on met pas un
parking on n'en fait pas un musée on
n'en fait pas un entrées payantes c'est
là et c'est ça qui m'exaspère c'est
sidérant c'est la pyramide du louvre est
bien mais je m'en fiche à pyramide du
louvre s'aimer soi même c'est la même
question mais non c'est pas une question
c'est pas notre dame de paris notre dame
à paris c'est un lieu religieuse mais le
louvre c'est par les religieux mon sens
de boire notre de paris elle est
accessible et géniaux l'imac raymond
mais pas un parking ont fait pas des
visites pour les touristes
et si les gens et laïque si les gens qui
incarne cette religion lévesque en
l'occurrence et bien sache la maquette
dit l'évêque l'hôtellerie c'est très
inquiétant l'archevêque en plus mais
parce que je suis c'est vous qui les
catholiques que vous manifestement tout
cas je connais mieux qu'il ya du
catholicisme de gauche
ou alors ça d'une femme c'est un leurre
pour agiter des gens comme moi et pour à
la fin
finalement vous avez vous faut-il
inclure de l'art contemporain dans le
projet de reconstruction de notre dame
de paris
telle est la question que nous vous
posons sur twitter et la réponse est non
à 84%
nicole 06 nous dit arrêtons de toujours
vouloir ajouter une touche contemporaine
partout mais quand même il ya chardons
bleus qui nous dit justement on a
critiqué la pyramide du louvre et ap
et pourtant à présent tout le monde la
trouve bien et puis pourquoi pas
ajoutent ils si c'est du beau
contemporain art coûts ce qui annule un
autre qui parle de archos mieux notre ne
me paye et puis archos 10 qui lui
considère qu'il faut garder l'art
d'origine mais avec des mécaniques aider
les matériaux modernes où il ya ça aussi
effectivement quand il ya des règles pré
l'origine
simple gaulois romains oui plupart des
cathédrales ont été bâties et la place
de temples romains donc l'origine c'est
quoi c'est le temple romain où c'est la
cathédrale catholique il a priori a
quand même un objet social entre
guillemets ci même s'il sait qu'il
maintient le fait de fêter que ce
système a été détruite par les chrétiens
pour en mettre une voix très bien on va
remettre des croix dans le panthéon pour
rappeler que c'était l'église sainte
geneviève et je précise que les les
vitraux de reims quand vous a montré son
de chagall les mais il ya des vitraux de
braquo ci qui sont magnifiques
en normandie les normands de tout ça a
bien oui mais c'était encore une fois
c'était ont changé débit trop qui avait
été détruit et que là le sujet dont on
parle c'est du bricolage parfois changer
des vies trop bon parce qu'il
utiliserait parce qu'ils étaient un peu
usés en lui vendant à changer puisque
les inscrits n'est pas comme la
nouveauté non ça se fait pas comme ça
parce que les règles globales sont
respectés et elle aime bien oui mais il
ya la commune est en prise avec son
temps et à la charte de vienne ya la
commission nationale du patrimoine ya le
ministère de la culture il ya beaucoup
de structures quand même d'un média qui
fixe des règles donc on peut lancer les
idées qu'on veut une enseigne un peu de
libre de dire ce qu'il veut mais en une
il y aura des règles et des lois à
respecter avant de se lancer dans des
aventures et la force de loi ah bah oui
la commission nationale patrimoine ou la
commande de venise non sur venise mais
vous disiez viennent cette charte de
venise en fait c'est un principe selon l
accord de bonne volonté
voilà c'est ça il faut mais elle n'a pas
n'a pas valeur contraignante
contrairement aux normes européennes
hélas ceux qui viennent y venir à
bruxelles
ouvrir ici des vitraux modernes ne vont
pas dénaturer la cathédrale ajoute
cordons bleus dont on a comparé donc de
pardon donc ton d'un cran furlong lui
qu'il était favorable à ce que il y est
une modernisation
sur le principe c'est à qui tu décider
parce que vous disiez laurent joffrin
pour vous en réjouir si c'est l'avis de
l'archevêque qu'on le fasse mais
à qui appartient une cathédrale alors
légalement elle appartient à l'état mais
vous me posez une pole je payais je
crois qu'il ya un accord en fait avec
les prélats qui se chargeait de les
fédérer l'a absolument les responsables
du diocèse qui en sont qui en ont la
charge il ya un mot juridique pour ça
que j'ai oublié non mais au delà du
droit
d'un point de vue concret est ce que on
devrait demander leur avis aux parisiens
ou aux catholiques parisiens ou bien
c'est un peu comme françois mitterrand
qui dit moi je vais construire le
l'opéra bastille et écologie conforme là
là la démocratie démocratie dans
l'église catholique s'est pas exactement
la philosophie l'origine non ça c'est
plutôt le peuple qui décide de tout
puisqu'il est infaillible
donc il est récemment c'est le genre de
sujet je crois il a le droit d'être payé
sur ce journal mais mais c'est pas
seulement une plaisanterie jamais vu ça
on voit bien que notre réaction que et
qui partagé largement par nos
internautes que ça fait pas l'unanimité
alors est ce qu on dit on va ne touchera
rien comme ça on fera le moins des
accords possibles ou est-ce qu'on
consulte les gens qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
d'une façon ça fait des années des
décennies que sans consulter les
ouailles on décide de changer le
mobilier le statuaire les chaises des
églises pour faire des choses modernes
de toute façon c'est une force qui va
comme de laurent joffrin à l'intérieur
de l'église
badou seulement depuis vatican ii même
même auparavant on est loin du syllabus
de 10,64 qui refusaient le progrès à
tout prix ce mouvement de progrès
existent depuis des décennies c'est une
sorte de deux réalités et il n'y a pas
eu de réaction non plus d'hostilité
violente des ouailles catholique parce
qu'à un moment donné à quelque chose de
plus fort que si le mobilier moderne est
en bois ou en ciment qui est la foi qui
est la lumière qui est le lieu où on est
qui est un lieu de prière donc la
regarde et je vais reprendre l'exemple
de strasbourg il ya une horloge
vous connaissez sans doute la grande
horloge qui est
au fond près du coeur ces temps là
j'avais été fait je crois à la fin de la
renaissance ont été refaites ensuite un
peu plus tard et l'église catholique a
admis que alors qu'à l'époque elle avait
accepté ça de manière assez récente que
la représentation du cosmos ne soit pas
conforme du tout à la théologie
chrétienne d'origine et la reprise il ya
même une statue de copernic fin comment
s'appelle une fresque nous on voit qu'au
père n'est donc l'église a accepté que
copernic
alors qu'elle avait passées en procès
égalisé pour pour l'empêcher de diffuser
ses thèses sur le fait que le soleil est
un centre de l'univers et non pas la
terre et là c'est pareil donc les les
glisser adapté et cette horloge avait
fait selon l'esthétique de neuvième pas
de pas la question c'est arrivé c'est
benoît l'âge le prince ait laissé ses
fans et à l'adaptation c'est peut-être
qu'à un moment donné on peut arrêter de
s'adapter lorsque ça commence à basculer
dans quelque chose qui ne ressemble plus
à l'esprit chrétien c'est ça que je veux
dire c'est que c'est pas parce que
l'église à juste titre changé s'est
modernisé s'est adapté au xxème siècle
ont fait plus de croisades ont fait plus
d'un finition tant mieux pour autant il
faut pas tout jeter il ya un moment
donné il ya des frontières il ya des
limites et je trouve que par exemple
notre dame de paris
compte tenu de son histoire de ce
qu'elle incarne de son rôle central
capital dans l'histoire de france et de
la chrétienté européenne devrait avoir
une sorte de statut
d'extraterritorialité est resté comme et
les avec un minimum de changements
et comme vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure
ce n'est que mon avis mais il était
néanmoins passionnant et merci non mais
christophe daniel si on revient à
l'origine il faut repeindre cathédrale
faut tout reprendre
parce que les murs étaient au chrs parce
que c'était un système à dieu c'est de
l'or mais là on en revient à l'origine
tant que justement on a ça évolue en
arrière toute
merci beaucoup à tous les deux merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis très bon week
end et à lundi
[Musique]